in my last podcast when I was taking the
you know the allegations of white
supremacy off of me
I mean to some degree they had come
because I hadn't jumped on the bandwagon
in calling Trump a racist for specific
things like telling Ilan Omar and the
rest of the squad to go back to where
they came from right it that didn't seem
like a clean example of racism to me and
I you know I've always said that I think
Trump is a racist and I see examples of
racism you know in his you know bio but
even someone who you know is a racist
you you can't hold them accountable for
for everything that can possibly be spun
as evidence of racism when it's when
it's bad evidence of racism because if
that evidence is going to stand for
Trump it has to it will then stand for
other people right
so no we're all going to be hosted by
that same news because it's it's just it
has to be Universal izybelle so if if
telling someone to go back to where they
came from is a sure sign of racism well
you have to be able to map it on to
other contexts and and here was the
context where I thought okay Trump is
such an imbecile he might not know that
the other three members of the squad
aren't also immigrants right he'll on
Omar came from Somalia right so that she
fit the type he was targeting maybe he
was just talking about her maybe he
thought that you know all of these women
have funny names they're probably all
immigrants maybe he didn't be I I don't
I don't give him the credit to have
thought about it for more than two for
even two seconds before his thumbs
started moving on his smartphone
right in a so that could be argued to be
kind of like an aggravating I mean I
don't need to go over that particular
case too much you could make the case
that it actually it was their
brown-skinned rather than their actual
country of origin that wound him up and
got him to say this and that in that
it's actually an aggravating factor for
making the case of actual racism one can
say that
no it could be it's just that I could
imagine a circumcision IRA and Ireland
with some failing state and you said you
know go back to you know go back to your
your own country and and you know solve
that potato famine and then tell us you
know how to run our lives
that wouldn't be racist you know from a
a you know a current white supremacist
point of view it would be you know it
would be an objectionable thing to say
perhaps but it's just not a you know it
just doesn't fit you know the racist
template and so it just wasn't good
evidence no but I mean is a white guy
saying Irish people should go back to
Ireland by definition it does it would
not be racist I don't know that it
proves or disproves the particulars of
that one does it no but my point is you
don't you don't need to be sloppy in
making allegations against Trump I mean
he's such a he there's so much attack
surface there right this this too much
right I mean this is another point about
him is that if he were one-tenth as bad
he would seem worse
I'm he's just so bad that we just we
can't even keep in mind the thing he did
at 10:10 a.m. this morning because by
2:00 p.m. he's done five other things
right so so I mean I think the left and
you know the end and by left here I mean
a mainstream journalism really suffers
from being sloppy here